[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARAN GOEL: Welcome
to day two of Next.
We're really excited
to have everyone here.
How's everyone's
afternoon going so far?
How was the lunch?
Free food, come on.
OK, so I want to set the
stage here, pun intended.
There's two really
kick-ass developers
that have come up with
this novel app idea,
just like we all do.
So they go back to their place
and they start working on it
and they pull an all-nighter
coming up with this app.
And then they deploy it.
They get a few users who
start testing their app
and they love it so
much one of them goes on
and submits to Hacker News.
Turns out, Hacker News
loves their app too.
Quite an irony.
They reach the number one
spot on Hacker News overnight.
They get thousands and
thousands of visitors,
but their servers were not meant
to handle that kind of load.
They didn't do demand
projection and so
they could not know
that that would happen.
And so, it takes them
hours the next morning
to provision more capacity to
handle this additional load,
but by then it's a
little bit too late
and they've lost a lot of users.
In an alternative
universe, you have
a team of developers who come
up with the same app idea.
But this time they spend
a little bit more time
architecting their
app based on the best
practices like micro services.
And then they deploy
it to App Engine.
This time, also, they don't
have to project any demands,
know how much traffic to expect.
The only thing they did was
deploy it to App Engine.
They go get a few users
to beta test their app.
Users love it so much they
submit it to Hacker News again.
And again, it gets
thousands of visitors.
But this time, based on the
load that the app is getting,
App Engine is able to scale
up their servers to handle
that additional capacity.
They are able to
capitalize on this success,
go raise more money,
and hire more people.
So let me just take a
quick poll in the room.
Who would rather be
in the first group?
Raise your hand.
Who would rather be
in the second group?
A few people.
So I've done this poll
before in my dry runs
and unanimously everyone wants
to be in the second group.
And my goal with this
talk, second group,
my goal with this talk
is to really motivate you
into giving App Engine
a shot and learning
a little bit about what
the second group did.
Hi.
My name is Karan.
I'm a software engineer
working on App Engine
for about nine months now.
And today I'd really
like to talk to you
about how you can write
scalable apps, high performance
app, that run on App Engine, and
how some thoughtful decisions
while you're making
your app can make
a huge difference in your
performance and scalability.
We'll be doing a
lot of cool demos
and towards the end we'll be
taking down a data center.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
So let's start with
the basics here.
What is App Engine?
And how many people
know about App Engine?
How many of you have used it?
A lot of people, wow.
So I'll just keep this short.
App Engine is a fully
managed platform
to deploy and run your
web applications or API
services with the
caveat that you
don't have to worry about
lower level infrastructure.
It's what we call
serverless infrastructure
where you just deploy your code
and don't worry about servers
or infrastructure.
The goal of the platform
is to abstract away
all the complexity that
comes with managing
this infrastructure.
And we just want
you to do what you
do best, which is write code.
And we enable that
by setting up a lot
of services behind the scenes
while you deploy your code.
We want our users to have
the same tools and services
that we've been using at Google
here for many, many years.
We want you to focus
on your business,
and growing your
business, and not
have to deal with servers
and reinventing the wheel.
Some of the services
that we offer
are things like Logging, hey
what's going on in my app?
Monitoring, what
happened at this peak?
I want to know what
happened at this spike.
Autoscaling, for cases when
you don't know what to expect,
how much load to expect,
and we can automatically
add and remove capacity.
Health checking, to make
sure the servers that
are serving your traffic
are healthy and up.
And Load Balancing to make
sure all your servers, again,
are healthy and don't
get too much traffic.
All these services let
you execute really fast.
And all you need to do is
either enable one option
or write one line of code.
And you'll see these
in demos again.
As developers, we just
want to execute fast
without having to worry about
scalability, or complexity,
or reinventing the wheel.
Together they all work to
make sure you can go from code
to Google Scale in moments.
In short, you bring the
code and we handle the rest.
And if you've gone to any
other App Engine session
you might have seen
this slide before.
It was in the keynote
earlier today.
And this is the philosophy that
the serverless infrastructure
at Google lives by.
You bring the code and
we handle the rest.
And all of this works to set up
engine [INAUDIBLE] because you
can use the
platform, whether you
have your first 10
users, your first 10
friends and family members,
or the next 10 million users.
So let's kick tires with a very
simple demo, Hello World demo.
I have a, for those
familiar with Node.js, this
is a simple GET handler
in Express.js framework.
All it does is
handle the root path,
compute a bunch of hashes,
and then update Firebase.
And you'll see why that happens.
Finally, it returns Hello World
with the last hash it computed.
So this is a normal,
everyday site
that I can run on
my local system
with node run, NPM
start, or node run.
Or I can run it on
Google's infrastructure.
And the only thing
that's different
is a two line config,
this two line config.
App Engine uses this
file called app.yaml,
which sets the configuration
for what your app's resource
requirements are, what
the network settings are,
things like what
service to deploy to,
what network settings to use.
So here is my app.yaml
that I'm using.
The first line tells
App Engine that it's
a flexible environment app.
The second line tells App Engine
that it's a standard Node.js
runtime app.
To deploy those all we have
to do is Gcloud App Deploy
and within moments your app
is set for the world to use.
So let's go to a
simple demo here.
Thank you.
So I'm in my Cloud Console
here where my app is deployed.
And you can see there's
one version deployed.
I'm going to do
something real quick.
I am in my GCE instance and I'm
starting a Locust web server.
And I'll explain what
Locust is in just a second.
So what I did here is,
Locust is a load testing
tool much like Apache benchmark
but comes with a web GUI.
And I am sending a peak of 200
users at a rate of about 20
per second.
So they're growing at a
rate of 20 per second.
So just to show
you what my app is,
again, I don't have
anything up my sleeves.
Wrong tab.
It's a simple Hello World at
the hash of the last time stamp.
So as you can see, I have
one version deployed,
but two instances running.
It's a Node.js app running
in the flexible environment.
If I go to my
instances tab, you can
see I have two instances
running right now.
Now, I could just claim
here that autoscaler is.
Running and as my
load is increasing
we'll add more instances
and you will be all good
but that makes for
a very boring talk.
So what I'm going to do is
explain it in 30 seconds
how autoscaler is working.
By default it's looking at CPU
usage across all my instances
and if it reaches 50% it
starts adding more capacity.
And this is something
I can configure.
I can change it to 20% if
I want to be below 20% CPU
all the time.
Or I can make it 80% if I
want to use my resources up
to that extent.
So all of this gives
you very fine control
over your particular app
and your specific needs.
You can also configure the
minimum and maximum number
of instances.
I didn't do that so by
default I got two instances.
But if I want six,
I can set six.
If I want 2000 I can set 2000.
So this lets you plan
for your budget knowing
the minimum and the maximum
instances that you can set.
So now as my app is
getting more and more load
I will switch to
this simple web app
where you can see the two
instances and the other three
are from my previous testing.
The two instances up there
are getting requests.
So what's there is,
these compute icons
represent the two
instances that I
have in my app that
are serving traffic.
And the pink bubble
with the number in them
represent the number of
requests each one of them
has handled so far.
So one of them has handled
14,000 the other one has
handled about 8,000.
And this is not a
App Engine thing.
This is just something
I wrote for this demo.
So now, as my app is getting
all this load from Locust
at about 166
requests per second,
App Engine has already
started all these instances
knowing that my requirement
for CPU has increased.
And there's seven
instances, I believe.
And any time now they
should be, there we go.
One of the instances is
now serving more requests.
So this is the one
very simple demo
where you can see
instances are being added
and as my load will start
to go away these instances,
the unused capacity
will also go away.
And if it could switch
back to the slides please.
So the Hello World
app scales just fine
and it's a very
simple example where
I compute a bunch of hashes
that consume some CPU.
But that's not very interesting.
That's not real life.
Real life is something
that has many moving parts.
It makes a bunch of
service requests.
It does a bunch of
database saves and reads.
So we're going to
try doing that.
For this demo I'm
going to use, I'm
going to make a small
part of Google Photos.
Who's used Google Photos here?
A lot of people.
So in Google Photos you
can upload your photos
and then search for them,
which is the coolest feature,
by the way.
So we're going to try to
emulate the labeling feature
and because it's a demo,
I'm going to keep it simple.
And all we will let our
users do is upload an image
and then see the top labels that
the Google Cloud Vision API is
able to find for those images.
And because I don't
have millions of users,
I have maybe a
couple in this room,
I'm going to try to
simulate that load using
the images I found
in this data set,
again, provided by
Google for free.
If it could switch to
a demo again, please.
Thank you.
So just to explain
again what is going on,
I have one photo here of
this construction site.
And I have a simple web page
that is blank right now.
If I switch to my
terminal and upload
this one image, what's
happening in the background is
my server is getting it, calling
the Google Cloud Vision API,
and then saving the labels
in in Cloud Datastore, which
is a No-SQL database by Google.
So now, if I
refresh my page, you
can see these labels are in.
And the CS is a little bit, OK.
These labels were
extracted from that.
So now we want to do this
for thousands of images.
Can we switch back
to the slides please?
Thanks.
So one implementation, which
is the easiest implementation,
is have one application,
one monolithic application
that handles the POST
request and the GET request.
The POST says, hey here's my
image, save it, get the labels,
and then save those labels.
And the GET request will
then return whatever
result we want to return.
But this really isn't ideal
because packing resource
intensive requests with user
requests on the same machine
can cause your
application to crash.
If a lot of my users are
uploading their images
and I'm running heavy processing
on the same machine that
has to respond to
user requests, this
could result in very high
latencies for my users.
And if, for some reason,
my POST end point is down,
that means my GET
endpoint is also down.
So this really is not the best
implementation we can go for.
The solution here is to
architect our application
with microservices architecture.
And App Engine,
in its foundation,
has microservices in it.
Each application can have
multiple services which
map to each type of request.
And each service that you
can see on the graph, which
is the second row, is fully
isolated from other services
and can be invoked
by HTTP requests.
Further, each service can
have multiple versions.
And each version corresponds
to, say, your releases.
So if I have a v1 and I have
a v1.1 each of those can be
a separate version that I
can send different amounts
of traffic to if I want to.
So knowing that, we
can decompose our app
into these two services.
The one on the left, the vision
service, is the POST end point,
effectively, where my
user submits an image,
we do some processing,
and save the result.
And the web front-end, which
is the service on the right,
serves an HTML page
with all our top labels.
But this also is not ideal.
And we're still running
into the same bottleneck
that if my users submit a lot
of images at the same time,
the requests will
start getting queued up
because my resource
intensive process is
taking a lot of time.
And eventually, they
might even timeout,
which means my users won't be
able to upload more images.
This is not the user experience
that we want to have.
And this can be solved
with autoscaling,
but only to a certain
point because you
will be spending a lot of money
having all those servers up.
So to fix this problem we
again decompose our app
into these three services.
And I promise this
is the last one.
The vision API service,
the one on the further,
on the left side, is just
the plain POST end point.
And all we do there
is, when we get
an image we send a
message to Pub/Sub,
which is our worker queue.
The one in the middle,
the vision backend,
does the heavy
processing of that image,
whether that's
running ImageMagick,
whether that's running your own
custom machine learning model,
or, in my case, calling
Google Cloud Vision API.
And the one on the right is the
same frontend service we have.
So Pub/Sub, for those not
aware, is a message queue
to talk between
independent services.
And its also not an
App Engine concept.
Its a Cloud service, which
is available from all layers
of compute.
So finally, after
all of this work,
we have this pretty solid,
but extremely scalable,
architecture that follows
App Engine best practices.
I know you are thinking,
this is a pretty scary graph.
So I'm going to take
some time to walk
through each
individual component
and explain as I've
implemented them.
So first we have the
vision API and all
this is, here's my image.
Please save it.
In my case I wrote it in Go
and it publishes a message
with that image to Pub/Sub.
In the center of the slide
is the vision backend,
which receives the image through
Pub/Sub from the vision API.
It then calls Cloud Vision API,
which is one of our ML, machine
learning APIs, takes the
labels out of the response
and then saves it in Cloud
Datastore, which is a fully
managed No-SQL database.
The service is
written in Node.js.
And if you've noticed, I
can have different languages
in each service.
So because my user facing
API has to be really fast,
I implemented it in Go.
This could be in Node,
so I wrote it in Node.
And on the right side is
my web frontend, which
is the frontend that my users
will use to see a list of all
the top labels they have.
This will pull
results from Datastore
and also this is
written in Node.js.
So I can really mix
and match the languages
I want that are best
for the use case
that I'm writing my app for.
And if we could switch
to the demo real quick.
Want to do a quick
walk-through of the code
here because code rules.
So just to show that there's
no shenanigans going on I'm
just going to do a quick
walk-through of the code.
And this is a simple Go
Server for our Vision API.
What I'm doing here is
initializing my Pub/Sub client
in three lines of code.
I am subscribing to
the topic and then
I'm initialising the
Firebase reference.
This is again for
visualizing in the web app.
In my endpoint, the
meat of my endpoint,
I'm extracting the URL that's
coming from the request.
And then after that, I
publish it to Cloud Pub/Sub,
right here.
And if you notice, again,
it's a single line of code
to do all this complicated
worker queue communication.
And then finally, I
update, right here
I update Firebase with
this instances name.
Next, we have the
vision backend.
This is the backend
that does, the worker
that listens for new images
and then does the processing.
And similar logic, we
initialize our Firebase client,
I initialize my
Cloud Vision client,
and then I initialize
my Datastore client.
When I run my server
there is only one endpoint
that I have that will
extract the image URL
and then immediately return
a 200 response to the client
for lower latency.
Then we download
the image and then
call the vision client
detect labels method.
And this will call the
compute vision API,
extract all the labels.
And we dump everything that we
are not very, very confident
about.
So the 0.75 filter there.
And then finally, we store
all our labels in Datastore.
And the mapping here
is the label map
to the count of the
label we've seen so far.
So very simple.
After we save our
Datastore client
we again update Firebase
for tracking that instance.
Similarly, in the
last web frontend
we initialize our Firebase
client, our Datastore client,
we allow cross-origin requests.
And then, in our Home page
we render a static HTML page,
and then we have a simple
JSON endpoint labels,
which will query Datastore
to get all our labels up
to a certain limit
and sort them.
So again, single line of code
to GET to query Datastore.
And then finally, we return
the response with our keys.
So let's play with
this a little bit.
I already have a
version of this deployed
and I'll do something
similar to what I did before.
I am in my Locust instance here.
And this time I'll
send up to 300
and ramp them up at
20 users per second.
So what's happening
here is, and we'll
be able to see it better here,
I have one instance running
and I could set
this in my app.yaml.
I have one instance running
that is handling all my frontend
requests.
Now, I'm going to simulate some
users by sending 1,000 image
URLs at a pace of about 5 per
second in batches of five.
And this is just
a simple wrapper
around Curl, which sends five
of them at the same time.
So you can see my Vision API has
started getting some requests
and my backend is
starting to process them.
So while this is
happening I want
to show you the Cloud Console
again and go to the Services
tab this time.
You can see on the web frontend
with one version running.
I have a vision backend
And I have the vision API
with one version running.
Vision API is in Go
with one instance.
Backend as one, Node.js.
And the frontend is
four instances now.
So within the last
30 seconds autoscaler
figured out that our load has
increased and already started
spinning up these instances.
And this one, again,
is in Node.js.
So while my app is warming
up, if we could switch back
to the slides.
I want to point a
few things out here
that I just slightly
glanced over.
First is just the breadth and
the depth of services and APIs
that Google Cloud
Platform has to offer.
We've been doing technology
for 18, 19 years now.
We've been working on Machine
Learning for a decade now.
And we would like our
users to have access
to all of those cool
services from databases
to Machine Learning to
monitoring, that power
product like Google Photos.
And you can have
access to all of that.
And as you saw, all it takes
is a single line of code.
And second, more
specific to our app,
is each service is very
specific and independent
and there is one thing it does
and it does it really well.
We make sure our latencies
are extremely low.
We make sure they can scale
up and down on their own.
And as my team
started growing, they
can control their own
independent deployment
processes further bringing
the risk of rollouts down.
Third, if my, say my vision
backend service is down,
it doesn't hinder with
my user experience
of the API or the frontend.
And that is something
really powerful
where, even if some of my system
is down most of it is still up.
Finally, and I
mentioned this before,
my services can
scale independently.
If suddenly my users want to
show off my app because I'm
at a conference
like this one, only
my web frontend can
scale instances up,
which results in a better use
of resources and hence my money.
So let's see how
our app is doing.
And if it could switch
to the demo again.
Perfect.
I go to my instances tab here.
And you can see we have
spun up 15 instances.
Not sure how easy it
is to see back there.
We've spun up 15 instances.
And web frontend is
already serving my request
with three of these
instances now.
And this is something
really powerful
where we only had to
wait for a few moments
to see this almost real
time scaling happen.
And so, while we
are still here, I
want to go back to
my default service.
And this is the
service that I used
in my first demo for the
Hello World with hashing.
And what I want to show
you is the monitoring
that we provide
with our service.
And you can see, in
the summary graph
we can show you how many
requests per second you
were getting.
So it is getting about 180
or something like that.
The second one I
want to point you to
is the CPU utilization
graph where
you can see a nice curve of
how my CPU utilization was
happening.
And based on this I can
again plan for my peak hours.
And finally, and this
is the coolest one,
is the instances graph.
And you can see again,
for the longest time
we were at two
instances and then
some, the CPU load
increased so autoscaler
scaled my instances up to 6.
So this really gives you a
peek at how autoscaler works
and that's what we want to
do to have, transparency.
The one thing I
should mention is,
this scaling is happening
based on the CPU consumption,
but you could configure it to
be QPS, or requests per second,
as well.
OK.
If you could switch
back to the slides.
Thank you.
OK, so for the final demo.
And this will really
highlight how resilient
our infrastructure is.
I promised I'd take down a
data center, I'm sorry, I lied.
I couldn't get all the approvals
there's processes and customers
that we need to take care of.
So we'll do the next best
thing and this will still
be worth your time.
We'll pretend that a
data center is down.
So for some context, all
App Engine deployments
are multi-zonal.
Whenever you deploy
you can choose a region
to deploy to and
within that region
we add a layer of replication
across multiple zones.
So on screen here you can
see some of our regions.
And each region is
in the blue row.
And within each region
we have multiple zones.
So in my case, I
deployed to US Central,
which has four of these zones.
So my app is replicated
across three of those.
And that really happens to
manage failures and improve
latency.
And, as some of you know,
failures in data centers
happen.
Some of you might have
had outages last week.
So what I want to
show here is if there
is a data center outage we can
still be in a good position.
If it could switch
to the demo here.
OK, I'm nervous for this one.
I'm not going to lie.
So I want to tell you
what's happening here.
I have the same Hello World app
that I used in the first demo.
And I am going to
start my local server.
And we'll do 200 users,
ramp it up at 5 per second.
So I have the same
Hello World app.
And I would be happy
to show you the app.
All that does is, Hello
World, it does some hashing
and I'll show you
the code in a second.
But this time, what's
happening is, in every request
it looks at the
metadata of the server.
So each project has
metadata and each instance
has access to that metadata.
When it sees that
the app is currently
in a zone which we want to take
down, it responds with a 500.
And this happens for
health check as well.
And the health check
bit is important
because that's the
signal that autoscaler
is using to take instances
in and out of rotation.
And so what I'm going to do, and
we'll switch back to this app.
Oh, sorry.
Yes.
So you can see I have four
of these instances currently
serving my request.
What I'm going to do is
take down US Central 1A.
And so what this
command does is,
it updates the project metadata
to have this failure zone
field, which is currently
set to US Central 1A.
And as soon as that is
done, so it's updated.
So looks like none of our
VMs were in US Central 1A.
So just for theatrics I'll
take down another zone.
So now, if you notice, US
Central 1 had four zones
and I'm pretending that
two of them are down.
Half of the region is
completely down at this point.
And at this point, if our VMs
were in the correct zone, well,
it looks like demigods
are not on my side.
Oh no.
OK.
Anyways, we'll keep moving.
So with that, I promise
there was no magic here.
So I'll show you
some of this code
and how I implemented this.
This is again in Node.js.
I'm curious.
[LAUGHTER]
So the way I implemented it I
have three endpoints to find.
One for the zone of
the current instance.
OK, there we go.
Two of these
instances are out now.
[SIGHS] Thank God.
So, if you notice,
the second instance
and the fourth instance have
stopped serving requests.
And I don't know
what happens next.
The failure zone one is
a custom field I defined.
And the failure zone two is
a second field I defined.
I do the same Firebase
initialization.
And then, before
I start my server,
I query my metadata server
and set the app zone field.
And so, this is just telling
me I'm in US central 1BCAF.
And then, I have this AH
Health endpoint that I defined.
And what it does is,
it gets the metadata
from the first
attribute field and then
checks to see if my instance
is in the same zone as my app.
Or, sorry, if my instance
is in the zone where
I want the failure to happen.
And if it does, it short
circuits and returns
500 status code.
If it doesn't, it
does the same thing
for the second one, and then
short circuits with a 500.
In my root path I check if
we are in a failure zone
again, if the failed bid is set.
And if it is, send
500, otherwise
do the same hashing
to consume some CPU
and update the instance.
And then finally, we
return Hello World.
So this is really, really
testing our infrastructure.
And if you notice, on other
instances was just spun up,
but these two instances are
still not serving any traffic.
And soon enough they'll be gone
as soon as those instances are
terminated.
So what happened here is, more
and more of these requests
are coming in and more and
more CPU is being used.
And autoscaler noticed
that and then tried
to add more capacity.
But the instances
never went healthy
so it never added
them to the rotation
where it can start
serving the traffic.
So the load balancer never
sends the traffic back
to those instances.
And I think that's a really
cool thing for us to see.
And you can see we're up
to about 35,000 requests
to our instance now.
So if we can go
back to our slides.
OK, so what did we learn today?
Well, first of all, demos
are really freaking hard.
Practice this a lot of times,
but everything, something
unexpected happens.
But on a more serious note,
we are all spending hours
and hours writing the
best code that we can. .
We're going to conferences like
these and learning the best
practices but it really sucks
when a machine cannot play
nicely with our code.
And that happens all the time.
Some machine goes
down, someone else
does makes a typo and
something happens.
So it's really
important to defer
managing those machines
to people who've
been doing this for many years.
And this really lets
you focus on your code
and writing the best
code that you can write.
Second, some thought in
architecting your code
and following some
best practices
goes a really long way.
Think about all the places
where your app might be doing
too much and then break it up.
This keeps their deployments
and rollouts independent
and reduces risk when you do
have to roll back a release.
Just also make sure your
resources, as you saw,
are being used more
efficiently, which
means a better
use of your money.
Finally, I would invite
you to try App Engine.
Give it a shot for
your next project
and it might just
surprise and delight you.
If you're curious to learn
more about App Engine
there's a couple more sessions
going out tonight and tomorrow.
And with that, I'd like to thank
you for attending this session
and I can take some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
We have questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for the
wonderful talk.
We'd love to get more
thoughts on your decision
to do the vision backend
behind a Pub/Sub.
I see you mentioned
you are trying
to throttle the
amount of CPU scaling,
can you tell us more about that?
KARAN GOEL: Sure.
So I'm just using Pub/Sub
as a queuing mechanism
because if my server
doesn't ack to Pub/Sub,
Pub/Sub will keep retrying.
So I could have used
ZeroMQ if I wanted to,
but Pub/Sub is just
something I can
use on Cloud's infrastructure,
on Google's infrastructure.
AUDIENCE: But in
what case would that
try to increase more instances
because your web frontend
kept adding instances--
KARAN GOEL: Oh.
I see.
I see what you mean.
So if Pub/Sub keeps
sending too many requests,
if my users submit
a lot of requests,
and Pub/Sub is sending
enough requests to hit my CPU
threshold, then autoscaler
will add more capacity to it.
And so, it doesn't
matter how many
requests are coming in from
autoscalers perspective
for my app.
It's the CPU consumption.
So I could compute 100,000
hashes in one of the requests.
And if that takes enough
CPU that's the metric
that autoscaler will use.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KARAN GOEL: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Kind of had two questions.
One is about Pub/Sub
for breaking up
artwork versus Task
Queues, when would you
choose one over the other
because I know Task Queue has
some nice features that you
can pause work in the middle
and restart it and
do stuff like that.
KARAN GOEL: Right.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: And the
second question
was, for the microservices
architecture,
how would you keep all of
those separate services
in the same repo
as folders and then
have one app.yaml
file that says,
here are all my services
for this application
or are you breaking apart?
Because something we've
started toying with
and, for us, we do
drone deployments
so we would have to
have a huge drone
yaml file to deploy each part
of the repo for each service.
So I'm just curious how
you would approach that.
KARAN GOEL: OK.
So for the first
part of the question,
the Pub/Sub v. Cloud Tasks.
Pub/Sub is really more of a
real time messaging platform.
For this app I could
have used either,
but if I wanted very
low latency, real time
communication between
say, my mobile app
and my backend server, that's
where I would use Pub/Sub more.
Cloud Tasks it's more for
server-to-server communication
at this point.
It did emerge from
App Engine itself,
but you can still use it
within any layer of compute.
If that adds some clarity?
For the second part of the
question, it's about repos?
AUDIENCE: Just how you would
organize those microservices
and deal with deploying
the different services
independently.
KARAN GOEL: OK.
I think that really
depends on how you would
have your deployment process.
I think it adds a lot of
value to your organization
if each of the
deployment process
is separate because,
again, it reduces the risk.
You don't deploy one
large monolithic.
So I think it would make sense
to have a separate deployment
process for say, your frontend
service where one of the team
takes ownership of it.
For organization
of the code base
I would say you could
have the same app
with multiple folders, each one
corresponding to your service.
And then you could maybe have
some wrapper scripts that CD
into the directory and
to a Cloud App Deploy
and then break out if
something goes wrong.
AUDIENCE: OK thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
We have an app that's running
in the standard environment,
in Java.
And I was wondering what the
future of supporting later Java
versions is, in the
standard environment,
or if it's something
where we should
start looking towards migrating
to the flexible environment?
KARAN GOEL: I'm going to
have my PM Justin Beckwith
answer that because he
knows more road map stuff.
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Yeah
so, whoa, that was loud.
Yeah, the standard environment
isn't going anywhere.
We're continuing
to invest in that.
One of the announcements
that we actually had,
for those of you that are part
of the Cloud insiders group,
is that, actually,
our support for Java 8
went alpha last week on
the standard environment.
So we're going to
continue supporting that.
We're going to continue growing.
We're going to get
new languages, later
versions of languages.
It's going to keep
getting better.
And both standard
and Flex are going
to do that at the same time.
The one thing that
is going to change,
that you should be
ready for, is how
we support the libraries that
you run within these run times.
Today, when you want
to access something
like Datastore,
Memcache, Task Queues,
you're using a very specific
kind of library for App Engine.
What we've been doing is writing
these things called the Google
Cloud Client Libraries, we
have them out on GitHub,
and the idea is
that we want to able
to use the same libraries
for App Engine, Container
Engine, Compute Engine,
and be able to access
all of our services.
Not just databases, not just
the App Engine services,
but things like Cloud ML, the
Vision API, a lot of the demos
that Karan was giving today.
So when you start
thinking about how you're
writing your apps in
standard, any opportunities
you have where you can use those
Google Cloud Client Libraries,
for Java there's a very good
one, start looking into that.
And you're going to see
better support from us
in the next couple of
months there as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering in
an App Engine Flex
specifically, how do you deal
with a sudden spike in traffic?
All of a sudden you went
from two requests per second
to 5,000.
How fast do the
instances spin up
in order to not lose requests?
KARAN GOEL: So in
my experience it's
ranging anywhere from
about a minute and a half
to two minutes.
So if your traffic is
extremely spiky and it it
spikes up within a minute
or a minute and a half,
then you're going to
lose some traffic.
But if it's for a
sustained period of time,
then we'll be able to add
more capacity to that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
KARAN GOEL: We're working
on making sure we bring
that down by a lot though.
AUDIENCE: OK.
KARAN GOEL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can we use Cloud Syrian with
App Engine load balancer?
KARAN GOEL: I believe you can.
AUDIENCE: I saw the document
is and I think it just
works with the load balancer.
KARAN GOEL: I'm not sure
I'm going to defer that.
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Yeah, so
that's something we're still
working on actually.
We're actively
building that out,
but you're going to be able to
just use the standard Google
Cloud CDN, hopefully the
next couple of months.
We don't know exactly when yet.
AUDIENCE: And just, I think,
how many maximum instances
we can have for a
project or for services?
KARAN GOEL: You can
request, I think by default
you're limited to 24 cores per
region, but if you want more,
you can request more up
to thousands of instances.
So if you need many,
many tens of thousands
we can work with you and make
sure we have enough capacity,
but we have customers
running tens of thousands
of course, hundreds of
thousands of course.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah my
question is, regarding
what are the comparisons
of AWS lambda
and the other Elastic
Beanstock for App Engine
features between the two
in case you are able to?
KARAN GOEL: I haven't
used either of those,
but I believe 80 PLUS Lambda
is more event-based kind
of like Google Cloud functions.
Yeah, I haven't
used those either
to make a comment about that.
AUDIENCE: Lambda automatically
provisions whatever,
the compute and all the,
it's serverless, right?
So--
KARAN GOEL: Right.
So the one difference I think
is, we're also serverless,
but here you get a little bit
more flexibility in that you're
still able to SSH into the
VM if you have any issues
that you're unable to debug.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KARAN GOEL: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
There isn't
currently a cloud API
for caching equivalent
to Memcache in App Engine
standard.
So what's the guidance on
running a caching fleet
when connecting from Flex?
KARAN GOEL: Does
Justin know that?
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Sorry.
Yes.
So we have a cloud
Memcache service
that's currently in alpha.
So if folks are
interested, pop into our,
we have a Slack
channel for App Engine,
by the way, or contact Karan
and we can get you in touch
for that, signing up for that if
you're interested in getting in
on the alpha.
The other thing that we have
is we have a partnership deal
with Redis Labs, is one
of our preferred partners
for providing Redis
and Memcache solutions.
And they run in the
same zones that we're
running App Engine Flexible.
So if you're
looking for Memcache
either those are good options.
KARAN GOEL: OK well, thanks
for attending and make sure
you check out later tonight and
tomorrow the two other sessions
about App Engine.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]